no he estado casada pero si queremos
casar es un plan a futuro
[Risas]
si tuvieras que compararse con otros en
función de un rasgo específico qué
dirías sobre cómo los ves y cómo te ven
para averiguarlo trajimos a cinco
parejas para que se organicen entre sí
según su supuesta diferencia de edad
después los ordenaremos según su
verdadera diferencia de edad esto es
clasificación cual pareja tiene la mayor
diferencia de edad cuánto tiempo llevan
juntos así lo hacemos en orden si
estamos a punto de cumplir un año en dos
días que es otra
llevamos cuatro meses juntos si es
en marzo si en marzo de este año no de
este último año casi un año llevamos
casi un año nos conocimos entender
llevamos 6 veces juntos si
aproximadamente la desempleada voy a la
escuela de enfermería
y viendo al entrar y ver todas esas
parejas me sentí como si yo fuera la más
viejita trabajo en un gimnasio de
américa ninja guardián se interesó en
aprender a pasar obstáculos y fue algo
mágico nuestras energías coincidieron y
somos músicos
soy estilista canina yo soy estudiante
todavía me gradué la escuela el año
pasado tengo mi licencia de bienes
raíces mi certificado de entrenamiento
personal si bien cuando estalló el cob y
todavía estaba en la escuela de la
universidad me gradué durante la
pandemia
que dije algo malo
pero todos pueden ir a la universidad
eso es sonrío de asiento en la escuela
quien vive con sus padres o viven por su
cuenta
tengo mi propio apartamento y ella
siempre está siempre estoy allí vivo
pero si me fuera a vivir con ella
tendría que pagar renta y con mis padres
no ustedes si viven juntos vivimos
también vivimos juntos en casa de mis
abuelos
vivo con mi abuela y mi madre vivo con
un compañero de piscina pero siempre
estamos juntos
levanten la mano si creen que esa que es
mayor
eres mayor correcto en serio creo que
esa química y la fueron a la escuela
juntos así lo percibo también merecen
tener la misma edad levanten la mano si
creen que mía es mayor
nadie más
difícil porque todos pensamos que con su
gorrita los accesorios y los tatuajes
tenían menos edad la observaba buscando
alguna pista
[Risas]
si creen que john es mayor levanten la
mano está muy difícil
creo que si your say soy mayor y tienen
más o menos la misma edad comportaba eso
también parecen bastante similares sus
experiencias y cómo se comunican entre
sí si crees que soy mayor levanten la
mano no lo soy
si creen que soy mayor levanten la mano
[Risas]
están casados sólo están pensando
no me he casado pero si quiero casarme
igual yo no nos hemos casado todavía
queremos casarnos es un plan a largo
plazo
lo antes posible pero esperaré de
acuerdo
y
lo prepare todo
no había pensado seriamente en el
matrimonio hasta que conocí a matrix o
por qué no dijiste eso dices tú
siento que es una pregunta muy
grave yo también quiero casarme no me he
casado él tampoco no es un concepto al
que me oponga
[Música]
matrix y yo no sé pero siempre me
equivoco
me parece que deberían estar en el
extremo de su especie pero sólo uno solo
un lugar que tienen una gran diferencia
de edad pero
yo también pensaba eso pero ahora no
pienso igual sacras trixie jon baja en
uno donde cree intercambiamos aquí bien
también tengo otra pregunta cuando están
con sus amigos o familia qué piensan
ellos de su relación si es bueno primero
mentir sobre su edad y luego volví a
mentir y luego le dije a mi madre su
verdadera edad y me dijo está bien no
sabía deberían quedarse ahí
y
ustedes mis amigos y familia pensaban
por qué
mis amigos cuando se enteraron al
principio dijeron lo mismo porque
estaba
sorprendida
mi madre me apoyo mucho mi amiga estaba
un poco preocupada al principio yo le
dije sólo conoce lo verás en nuestra
relación y lo vas a igualdad sí creo que
ustedes y si también te apoyan y yo creo
que estos tres pares están muy siento
que deberían cambiar no sé si estos
quiero ver sus caras si
eso
lo quieren cambiar
[Risas]
los demás
deberíamos creer en ti esta vez una
oportunidad
saben qué manera
bien es verdad
ahora los ordenamos según su edad real
con la menor diferencia de edad tenemos
un año con zac y me jala
en la siguiente tenemos un empate entre
dos parejas seis años tanto para braille
y hunter como para matrix y jon
en julio
octubre julio octubre noviembre y
diciembre
entonces son dos meses
que está técnicamente aquí
ccss en el segundo puesto tenemos a
jamie y ángel
[Música]
es
verdad
nosotras pensábamos
en el puesto número 1
con 16 años
espera cuántos años tienes 20 años qué
crees que tiene
que no parece tener 30 y sólo valerosas
el
mayor pero empezamos allá así ahora
que
no quiero entrar en detalles pero siento
que también es algo religioso
sí sé que nuestras familias son muy
religiosos siempre dicen tienen que ser
de cierta forma si eres feliz no importa
si seguro a veces olvidó que tiene 31 y
vosotros también lo olvidan y es como
mira esto y él dice no entiendo que es
verdad porque es un
puntito que ya está como no lo entiendo
y yo no importa a veces la edad es sólo
un número
de acuerdo a veces la edad no define
necesariamente la madurez por supuesto
tiene que ser legal así es se trata más
bien de la vibra y si tienen cosas en
común pueden que funcione fue una locura
porque hay muchas parejas que miras y te
parece que no tienen sentido pero todos
aquí parecían encajar muy bien todos
juntos siempre pensé que seis años nos
separaban mucho y luego ver parejas de
12 y 16 años definitivamente cambió mi
forma de vernos es normal tener esa
reacción sabiendo la gran brecha que
tenemos porque todos se sorprenden al
momento o porque pero lo entienden
después de un tiempo sí
[Música]